[Music]
Nicole Kidman gushes over husband Keith
Urban's new tunes hey yeah I'm always
ready for new music as the country star
pays tribute to the late Tom Petty
during CMT's artist of the year event
[Music]
[Music]
pushing me around
[Music]
tell me about that experience and
rehearsing for it yeah it's such a
perfect song for everything that's been
happening in the last couple of months
the strength and the fortitude of the
country fans is unbelievable so we
wanted to acknowledge that tonight is
really all about them Keith yesterday
about working on new music in the studio
very excited here what do you think of
what he's cooking up I'm dancing around
the living room to it alright you're
ready for the album to be out yeah yeah
I'm always ready pretty amusing working
on a sense really January February so
these songs have been permeating our
house for a year now so I'm anxious to
get any music out we worked I and now I
sort of I hear how they change and it's
really fascinating he's such a I mean a
maestro you know when are we gonna get a
duet with you to the end of the show we
talked a little bit yesterday about Luke
joining Idol to ask you one more time
about advice that you have for him
no I was just talking him stuff to noon
at soundcheck and he's having a blast so
I'm dying to see the show watching of
course I love Idol
you